hey youtubers is Charlie so they're
doing the Superman thing again
reportedly there is a Man of Steel 2
movie in development so I'm gonna do an
explanation for that whole bunch of
Superman stuff happening this week
between the movies and the TV shows so
here we go
so the big news is that there's a
reported Man of Steel sequel like a
Superman solo film that's actively being
developed by Warner Brothers so if you
didn't know what that means is is when
they say they're actively developing
something it's like your parents telling
you you're going to Disneyland and then
you're like well are we going right now
are we going next week and they say we
are going right now get in the car so
active development versus passive just
means they're devoting a lot of
resources a lot of human power to
actually figuring out what the story's
gonna be and how it's gonna fit in the
new DC Cinematic Universe because if you
were ever worried about them not doing
the Superman sequel don't worry about
that Superman and Batman are their two
biggest characters there will always be
Superman and Batman films but when
they're not actively developing
something it just means that people keep
pitching them ideas like hey I have an
idea for the next Superman movie and
they're like okay put it on the pile
we'll revisit it later so now Geoff
Johns the other executives that are
responsible for making decisions about
what movies get made have just like
gotten up out of their seats and said
okay everybody let's high five and
figure this out so what will probably
happen is is you'll hear more about this
new Superman movie when they get ready
to release Wonder Woman because even
though Suicide Squad is doing
gangbusters at the box office like it's
doing really really well
there's gonna be plenty more Suicide
Squad movies public perception isn't the
greatest like there's just a lot of
people that weren't satisfied with the
film so they just want to make everybody
as happy as possible when Wonder Woman
comes out so once that happens expect
them to start talking more about
Superman because the good thing about
Superman like if you're wondering what a
new Superman movie might feel like
because they're kind of slowly altering
the tone of the DC movies away from like
the really dark depressing gritty Zack
Snyder deconstructionist view the Wonder
Woman movie is kind of like the first
big course correction Geoff Johns was a
co-writer on it the whole conceit of
Wonder Woman is that the world is in
chaos like the fandom is in chaos and
she is here to make everything okay
again so like literally in the context
of the movie and metaphorically in the
context of the fandom that's kind of the
role
Wonder Woman is gonna fill next spring
so I'm expecting any new Superman film
to be closer to the tone of the Wonder
Woman movie so now you're all saying
who's gonna be writing it who's gonna be
directing it well I'll say right off the
bat
probably not Zack Snyder but the person
that they actually choose to make the
movie will depend a lot on the type of
Superman story they want to tell and the
funny thing is like most comic book
writers say Superman is like the least
fun character to write
he's just so overpowered that it's
really hard to have a villain that can
match him like you do lex luthor once
you can't do Lex Luthor every single
time he's a great villain for Superman
but we just did him in Batman vs
Superman
so there are only a few other slam-dunk
villains that you could do like Brainiac
is an amazing Superman villain the new
Krypton Brainiac arc from the comics
would be a really great straight like
Brainiac emerges Superman is one of the
only people that can help defeat him so
we already know we have Justice League
so we have Darkseid the new gods that's
gonna be a Justice League level problem
but the Superman solo film will have to
be a different antagonist that Superman
can face and defeat alone you know with
maybe a little bit of help from the
other Justice League characters because
like okay so spoilers for Suicide Squad
I'm going to talk about spoilers from
that movie because there was some
crossover so here we go so Batman in the
flash appeared in the Suicide Squad
movie in really small ways but it was
really interesting so expect that same
type of treatment in the other DC movies
like you'll see people pop up in other
people's movies so because it's probably
gonna be a couple years before we
actually see this next Superman film
we'll have already met a bunch of other
Justice League characters so there are a
number of different people that could
cameo in his film but for the most part
it's gonna be a challenge for the
Superman character to face alone so it's
just like really hard for them to tell
an awesome Superman story where he
either doesn't die at the end like
all-star Superman by Grant Morrison is
one of the greatest Superman stories of
all time but he dies at the end of that
story
you can't kill Superman in every single
one of his movies so they're just way
less Superman villains that are you know
very easy for them to do in a cinematic
way that would play really well in a
movie as opposed to Batman who has a ton
of awesome villains that they could
bring into the movie so that's one of
the reasons why it's so much easier for
people to write good Batman stories than
it is for them to write
Superman stories and I always feel like
in the back of my mind people are more
interested in trying to see man trying
to become God which is kind of what
Batman represents he's kind of like the
God of revenge
Superman is more like the story of a God
trying to be a man and in Zack Snyder
really elevated him to that level in
Batman V Superman everybody kept talking
about him like he was a god even in
Suicide Squad they talked about him as
if he was a god a god who's fallen so
I'll be really interested to see and how
they weave him into the new DC Universe
like a new Superman story because it'll
probably a combination of a couple comic
book arcs but I think that Brainiac
would probably be the slam-dunk villain
to that movie so let me know in the
comments what kind of Superman story do
you want them to do for the Man of Steel
sequel and remember because Steppenwolf
is going to be the villain of the
Justice League film the new gods do
exist so you could use some of the new
gods for a Superman solo story but you
can't really stuff too many new gods and
do a Superman solo story without it
turning into a Justice League story and
I think they want the next Superman film
to feel like a Superman film and not
like a Superman film with the entire
Justice League in it but for those of
you wondering when Warner Brothers is
actually gonna start talking about the
Man of Steel sequel publicly I would
expect when the Wonder Woman movie comes
out and then when comic-con comes next
year for them to have some sort of
presentation saying hey this is when the
Superman movie is coming here's just a
quick look at the stuff that we're
working on but I do feel like Aquaman
would work really well in a Superman
movie because this version of Aquaman is
almost as powerful as Superman just yeah
as long as he's close to water but I do
feel like Jason Momoa just like his
persona his Aquaman persona would play
really well with Henry cavils version of
Superman then you know they just have a
lot of charisma together when Aquaman
bites you it's his way of saying that he
likes you I can't wait to see Jason
Momoa interact with the other Justice
League characters too it's gonna be so
fun
the giveaway time though congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner Brian
Murray you won a $20 Amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details so if you didn't see my
flash Supergirl for night TV crossover
video that I posted yesterday I talked
about like the big panel that they're
having for the TV shows this week that's
coming Thursday so there'll be plenty
more TV DC stuff happening but there'll
be some more Marvel stuff there's a new
Luke Cage trailer that's going to drop
tomorrow so I'll be doing videos for all
that stuff be sure to subscribe to get
it so don't forget sweet Christmas
coming tomorrow what do you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here to learn all about the big 4 night
TV crossover and you can click here for
my Justice League trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight